[Music]
if you've been watching the news or been
on the car lot lately you know that car
prices have been
insane and with that comes some insane
decisions
and then with that becomes a new average
monthly car payment of
733 dollars according to kelly blue book
wow can that is insane wow
that's the average that's the average
wow and interest rates of course rising
so the average you know car loan
interest rates really tight georgia
starts four percent
so my chest
that's too much
because cars are getting more expensive
of course the car payment goes up
because that car that you would use to
pay 35 for is now 45 or 50.
and so here's a another i don't want to
give you a heart attack on air can but
the average price paid for a new vehicle
is up to a new record of 48 000
wow that is nuts
and so we like to react to some videos
here and so the producer sent us this
one uh that makes this number look low
you ready i'm gonna about take your
breath away is that right yeah you ready
for that better
ken has not
this is not method acting this is true
we're going to get ken's true reaction
roll that beautiful bean footage
sir what is your car payment
uh mine is 13.25 and what kind of
vehicle is that it's a 22 ford raptor
okay you have another payment i do
actually my wife's hers is a thousand
it's a 22 ford expedition
hey ma'am what is 4300 car payment
13.86 and what kind of car requires a
1386 payment a 2022 grand wagoneer
series 3. hey sir what is your car
payment
i got a couple of them but the
first one's
1445. what kind of car is that that's a
new gmc sierra 2500 denali
what's the other one uh it's a wide-body
ctsb that's 1161. i don't even know what
that is
wide body something oh
okay wow so here's what we just
witnessed for those of you listening on
radio
those people work at a car dealership
yeah and that's the real numbers okay i
was going to ask you where they're from
because they did you see the gal that
struck out to me stuck out to me when
she said he said it was the setup and
she literally went
like
it like just laughed it off like it's uh
you know like uncle larry and his gout
that we hear about every thanksgiving
you know it's like well here here it
comes i gotta go to thanksgiving at the
coleman's yeah well i don't actually
have an uncle larry and and gals nothing
to joke about it's true
but but then she was just so like well
this is what it is right i mean it's
like you're so cavalier about it oh yeah
here it comes like she knew the video
was coming she was like all right here's
your 1386 dollar carb i got to tell you
i have heartburn and i haven't had
anything to eat today i need a tums
right now there's some in the in the
studio bathroom right now okay i'll use
those during the so let's recap what
just happened these are folks that work
at a car dealership revealing how much
their car payment is and of course if
you work at a car dealership you get the
latest and greatest
and so all of those were brand new 22
raptor 1325 a month we got the gmc the
denali's 1445.
and
it hurt my brain ken it hurt my heart
more than my brain yeah one the first
couple when he talked about his wife's
car with his 2 300 a month in car
payments and this is and what's crazy
about this is that nobody thinks about
this this payment as going towards a
asset that is devaluing that's right
every mile you drive it it's losing
value it's not like a house
well and we we've got stats on this can
we know that the average car depreciates
at an insane rate i mean we're talking
40 50 60 depreciation after five years
oh boy so let's walk through
depreciation and then i'll do some other
math that will make you never want a car
payment again so the minute you drive
the car off the lot already nine to
eleven percent appreciation so let's say
you get a car for 35 grand one minute
later it's worth 31.5 dude i would
literally be the guy with that in my
back of my head i would be exiting the
car dealer parking lot and i would just
be like stuck i i couldn't press the gas
anymore they're like sir we need you to
leave the lot i'm like it's gonna drop
nine imagine just having four grand in
your pocket and throwing it out the
window when you leave the car alive
and that's not even with your interest
rate so you are paying interest
on a depreciating asset so one year
later the 35 grand car now worth 28. two
years 24. three years 21. four years 18.
five years later the 35 grand car is
worth 15 000
and this on average
so i did some math can as you know i
like to do
and if you invest that payment let's say
you got a reasonable car that was maybe
ten thousand dollars instead of forty
eight thousand dollars
and you instead invested that fourteen
hundred bucks
with compound growth let's say at a ten
percent rate of return over twenty years
that fourteen hundred dollars com that's
monthly so we're talking sixteen eight a
year
that turns into almost a million dollars
how do you like the car friends that's
your that car after 20 years ain't worth
nothing
you could have had a million bucks now
if it was 30 years you would have 2.7
million dollars
does that not make you go
maybe this is a bad financial decision
yeah okay but that makes too much sense
george you're right i'm sorry ken uh i
kind of my buddy's got the denali and so
i got to get the dooley to impress him
this is the deal so we think that we
deserve
to drive a nice car that's the first
problem this is this is inherently human
stuff i'm serious about it's like you
can't make sense with numbers because
that that doesn't that doesn't uh help
us with our humanness because our
humanness goes well look i gotta have a
car
and if i haven't got to have a car
safe and reliable and everybody's got a
new car and if i get the new car it's
got a warranty on it so i'll take it
down to the old gmc and get it fixed
it's all this reasoning and we kind of
talk ourselves into this narrative that
goes
yeah i don't want to hear that i
okay that's great george but i gotta
have a car
and this isn't this is really the
problem
that's the root of it and a lot of it is
comparisons if we're gonna be honest and
you want to have a facade that you're
successful
same never done it
um and you know i like old cars you're
an old soul but but let me give you
another little thing here all right so i
i've driven older cars you know just
like just late you know just normal
stuff but then i recently had the
opportunity to get a a a uh volkswagen
convertible karmann ghia that is worth
about 24 grand
easy 24 grand that's big time it's 48
years old no it's 50 something years old
right that's older than you it is just
barely thank you george what are you
saying i'm an antique
you could be if you were a car get my
point is like if you're gonna if you
like if you're gonna buy something if
you want a car then get something
classic that actually has some value but
all these new fancy cars
aren't worth crap
two years later you want to trade it and
get a new one
and a lot of this ken i'm going to throw
the guys under the bus here because
men are susceptible to this uh the
trucks truck guys are a certain breed
and you know dave ramsey's a truck guy
himself and of course he has a paying
cash
he's not making payments he's not paying
interest no but there's something about
truck guys and wanting to impress the
other truck guys yeah my truck's bigger
than your truck there it is and dave
always uses the joke if your truck
payment is bigger than your mortgage
payment you might be a redneck
oh listen i was listening to that uh
comedy roundup channel on siriusxm
because our show is on siriusxm and uh i
it was jeff foxworthy and he said uh
if
if you
uh are making out in the back of a truck
that is being towed to the repo you
might be a redneck that's brilliant you
know and there's your problem that's
quite the visual yeah i know well i
cleaned it up a little bit it's just one
of the things causing america to be
broke because you add that with the
student loan crisis
and living off of credit cards because
you need the rewards and the airline
miles that's right then you take on the
giant mortgage payment yeah because you
wanted to get into a home because you
were throwing money away on rent yeah
now we're talking thousands and
thousands of dollars going to lenders so
they can have big buildings downtown
while you remain broke forever so i want
to set some people free george please
nobody cares how big your truck is
nobody cares louder for the guys in the
back nobody cares how big your truck is
nobody cares how nice your truck is
nobody cares how nice your car is nobody
cares how old your car is nobody cares
if your car backfires when it pulls into
the parking lot like at the end of the
day everybody else has got their own you
know what going on in their life and
they're trying to deal with it they
don't care so why do you care what they
might think i got news for you
they don't care pastor ken just dropped
a sermon right there and if you're
embarrassed by your car guess what
there's always spaces in the back